I had a very difficult and in my own
head Brave leap that I had to take
relevant to our discussion which is most
of my life I programmed in C and C plus
plus
and so uh having that hammer everything
looked like a nail so I would literally
even do scripting in C plus plus like I
would create programs that do script
like things and uh when I first came to
Google and and before then it became
already before tensorflow before all of
that there was a growing realization
that c plus is not the right tool for
machine learning we could talk about why
that is it's unclear why that is a lot
of things
has to do with community and culture and
how it emerges and stuff like that but
for me they decided to take the leap to
python like all out basically switched
completely from C plus plus except for a
highly performant robotics applications
there were still uh
there's still a culture of C plus plus
in in the space of robotics
that was a big leap
like I had to you know like like people
have like existential crises or midlife
crises or whatever you have to realize
almost like walking away from uh from a
person you love
um because I was sure that c plus would
have to be a lifelong companion for a
lot of problems I would want to solve C
plus would be there and it was a
question to say well that might not be
the case because sibo spots is still one
of the most popular languages in the
world one of the most used one of the
most dependent on it's also still
evolving quite a bit I mean
that that is not a sort of
fossilizing Community yes they they are
doing great Innovative work actually a
lot but yet that sort of their
Innovations are hard to follow if you're
not already a hardcore C plus plus user
well this was the thing it pulls you in
it's a rabbit hole I was a hardcore the
all meta programming template
programming like I I would start using
the modern C plus as it developed right
not just the not just the shared pointer
and the garbage collection that makes it
easier for you to work with some of the
flaws but the detail like The Meta
programming the the crazy stuff that's
that's coming out there but then you
have to just empirically look and step
back and say what language am I more
productive in
sorry to say what language do I enjoy my
life with more
and uh readability and able to think
through and all that kind of stuff that
those questions are harder to ask when
you already have
a loved one which in my case was C plus
plus and then there's python uh like
that Meme was is the the grass is
greener on the other side am I just
infatuated with a new fad new cool thing
or is this actually going to make my
life better and I think a lot of people
face that kind of decision it was a
difficult decision for me
um when I made it at this time it's an
obvious switch if you're into machine
learning but at that time it wasn't
quite yet so obvious so it was a risk
and you know you have the same kind of
stuff with um
I still because of my connection to
Wordpress
I still do a lot of back-end programming
in PHP uh
and the question is you know node.js
python do you switch to do you switch
back into any of those
programming there's the case for node.js
for me well more and more and more of
the front end it runs in JavaScript
um and fascinating cool stuff is on his
JavaScript maybe use the same
programming language for the back end as
well
uh the case for python for the back end
is well you're doing so much programming
outside of the web in Python so maybe
use Python for the back end and then the
case for PHP well
most of the web still runs in PHP
you have a lot of experience with PHP
why uh fix something that's not broken
those are my own personal struggles but
I think they reflect the struggles of a
lot of people and with different
programming languages with different
problems they're trying to solve it's a
weird one and there there's not a single
answer right because depending on how
much time you have to learn new stuff
where you are in your life what what
you're currently working on who you want
to work with what communities you like
yeah there's not one right choice maybe
if you if you sort of
if you can look back 20 years you can
say well that whole detour through
action script was a waste of time
but
nobody could know that
so you can you can beat yourself up over
that
uh you just need to accept that not
every choice you make
is going to be perfect maybe sort of
keep Plan B in the back of your mind
uh but don't don't overthink it don't
don't try to sort of don't don't create
a spreadsheet with like where you're
trying to estimate well if I learn this
language I expect to make x million
dollars in a lifetime and if I learn
that language I expect to make why a
million dollars in a lifetime and which
Which is higher and what which has more
risk and where's the chance that it's
like picking picking a stock
kind of kind of but uh
I think with stocks you can do
diversifying your investment is good
with productivity in life
boy that spreadsheet is possible to
construct
like if you actually carefully analyze
what your interest in life are where you
think you can maximally impact the world
there really is better and worse choices
for a programming language they're not
just about the syntax but about the
community about where you predict the
community's headed
what large systems are programmed in
that but can you create that spreadsheet
because that sort of you're mentioning a
whole bunch of inputs that go into that
spreadsheet where you have to estimate
things that are very hard to measure and
even harder I mean they're they're hard
to measure
retroactively and they're even harder to
predict like what is the better
community
well better is is one of those
incredibly difficult words what's better
for you is not better for someone else
no but we're not doing a public speech
about what's better we're doing a
personal spiritual journey I can
determine a circle of friends
circle circle one and circle two and I
can have a bunch of parties with one and
a bunch of parties with two and then
right down or to take a mental note of
what made me happier right and that you
know you have if you're a machine
learning person you want to say Okay I
want to build a large company that does
that is grounded in machine learning but
also has a sexy interface that has a
large impact on the world what languages
do I use you look at what Facebook is
using you look at what Twitter is using
then you look at performance more newer
languages like rust or you look at
languages that have taken that most the
community uses in the machine learning
space that's Python and you can like
think through you can hang out and think
through it and it's it's always a invest
and the the level of activity of the
community is also really interesting
like you said c plus and python are
super active in terms of the development
of the language itself
but do you think that you can make
objective choices there no no well but
there's a gut you build up like don't
you don't you believe in that gut
feeling everything is very subjective
and yes you most certainly can have a
gut feeling and your gut can also be
wrong that's why there are billions of
people because they're not all right I
mean clearly there are more people
living in the Bay Area who have plans to
sort of create a Google sized company
then there's room in the world for
Google sized companies and they're gonna
have to Duke it out in the market the
space and there's many more choices than
just the programming language